hubba hubba hubba and playing whoo bar
this is a w GMA she recently completely
crushed me at I really remember this ad
was some kind of NIMH zoo Indian it was
some sunlight f3 stuff I believe not in
the Quincy 293 okay I'm going with the
sameish let's see how she doesn't dad
okay what was the name no no name okay
yeah that's the very old-fashioned way
to handle this opening with black like a
lon capa blanca with black roses board
Winnick that light always had a bad
reputation after that game i'm not sure
how bad it really is i think it's it's
not particularly great for black but
it's also not yeah no trade law anything
but black has to be quite precise to not
getting clobbered by whites a white
center next ideas from a to e 2 and
going for that
okay I don't want to track Queens that
much is clear so if I am go to f5 or
something maybe Quincy voice actually on
Quincy was a bit bit of an annoyance
interesting plan with Queen Essex I
wasn't really aware that this is a
possibility there that's pretty good it
seems
okay one drawback is that I maybe have
night f5 them game let's let's go that
and then see how it continues maybe just
route negotiate I've got ninety six
seven that's probably okay for me
so I'll play this here rookie 194 it
looks it looks immensely shaky this
position somehow and one that black just
has g67 just play g6 and now I'm doing
something that looks kind of terrible i
think but i'm thinking about taking on
c5 and gooey forward it's maybe a bit
too much strategically speaking between
f2 Queen g3 maybe
what the heck she completely killing me
again here and the night is hanging I
should pay attention to that okay taking
on g4 it's not yet threatened anyway
it's really a that the position sucks it
really sucks what happened them
okay let's do this if she takes be too
we should be too and I can take on c5
that is some at least active so I'm
taking this now
garruk chicks looks no then I've got 94
actually so pawn takes bishop f6 so
she's giving the exchange she really
wants to play like the beauty prize
against me all the time or what is
happening here she really killed me in
that in that game we had I don't know
last week or something it was one of the
toughest losses i can remember in recent
times so what now okay let's trade this
thing one minute 09 that's not so bad
yeah I think she has to trade queens now
I'm threatening Bishop f-16 age seven
unless she finds some big resource she
has to tread Queens and this one and I
think I'm grabbing this done Queen will
come to time learning to eat two or
something but I don't don't believe it
so let's see um g5 maybe a GF I'd King
back Queen h5 it's pretty awkward
I could take you Jack no well there's
III is hanging f this is also hanging
but isn't that something may be may be
here I just need to play moose in check
mmm Queen g4 man could add Quincy for
that was pretty simple actually check
nineteen seconds so can you take 25 ah
what a nightmare check check
check just 10 seconds here can take h2
no f5 hangs yeah this is pretty
enforcing check check check our time as
repetition after I've got seven seconds
and it is actually a draw yeah me never
I mean how much and how much were
winning position do you want this is a
this is just totally okay I didn't
manage to to end this really really
really really Quincy three years
curtains already Quincy seven made wow
just bad check Queen g4 was winning
instead of that check this then what
exactly King age 16 look what you won
yeah that makes some sense yeah
consolidate and then push the pawn yeah
I really didn't have a good position but
then she all of a sudden went into this
B takes I don't know it was I was
completely unclear i was thinking i have
a couple of ideas this is one of them I
wasn't really sure this is good okie an
engine says d4 is good for black no
that's also nighty seven then Bishop f6
but there's probably not enough yeah I
didn't have a good position but she just
basically blundered that exchange I
think that I'm not winning this is
really embarrassing okay thanks for
watching